a snow-covered bridge buckles and
collapses on friday morning in
pittsburgh
several cars and buses were on the
bridge at the time ten people suffered
minor injuries in an ironic twist just
hours later president joe biden comes to
see it firsthand he's on his way to
deliver a speech nearby remarkably about
america's crumbling infrastructure
eyewitnesses say the bridge collapse
could have been a lot worse if this had
happened 15 to 20 minutes later you
would have had buses with school kids on
it buses with workers
so the timing of this in terms of
happening when it did was very
fortuitous
the bridge was built nearly a half
century ago
like dozens across the city of
pittsburgh
the federal government rated it in poor
condition back in 2011. and more than
three years ago this twitter user
highlighted its corroded steel beams
it's unclear if it had ever been fixed
but it's not just in pittsburgh all over
america infrastructure is in disrepair
and that's why last year congress passed
and president joe biden signed into law
a 1.2 trillion dollar infrastructure
plan
to rebuild everything including railroad
lines airports
tunnels roads
and yes bridges
biden is using the bridge collapse to
champion the urgency of his hard-fought
infrastructure efforts across the
country there are 45 000 bridges in poor
condition
it's just simply unacceptable we have to
do something about this
i've talked about it every time i've
come to pittsburgh
and we finally got it done
according to the american society of
civil engineers in the u.s there are 617
000 bridges 42 percent are over 50 years
old and 46 000 bridges in the u.s are
structurally deficient
on friday the problems with bridges
abundantly clear for everyone to see
gabriel rosando al jazeera new york